a revolution is unfolding invisible
global and virtually impossible to avoid
more than 90% of the world's data
appeared in just the past two years
transforming everything from retail to
medicine many more patients will be
cured and many more patients will live
but this explosion of data is also
raising fundamental questions about
democracy
[Applause]
about privacy your User Agreement sucks
and about society's most basic freedoms
[Applause]
I'm horse won and 23:05 and her risk is
category one all right illunga hospital
Tennessee are you hurting anywhere the
medical staff here are at the forefront
of efforts to transform healthcare with
data and those efforts could make the
difference between life and death
first we thought hey she is significant
for hypertension Nick powers is one of
the latest patients to be rushed to the
emergency ward she's having great deal
of difficulty speaking
I seen a smile you give me a smile big
smile give me a big smile he's suspected
of having a clot in his brain right side
for Nick every second counts there is no
more time sensitive condition and in all
of medicine than stroke every hour
minute and seconds we can shave off the
diagnosis the better the patients will
do at many hospitals that can be
critical delays in analyzing brain scans
hours can go by before patients are
properly diagnosed and transferred for
emergency treatment but dr. Tom Devlin's
team is using a new data-driven tool
it's able to analyze a scan of Nick's
brain in a fraction of the time doctors
would normally take called vis AI it's
machine learning technology quickly
draws on fast amounts of medical data
gathered from years of research you can
see well yeah this technology has a
tremendous amount of data built in the
system of where these arteries are what
these arteries should look like and
where there should be blood flow and
when there's interruption in that blood
flow it sends off an alert can you say
today is
they say today is a sunny day can you
say that for me vis a I has identified a
clot that is blocking blood flow in
Nick's brain so right there is where the
blockage is so the goal now is to get
the clot out of the brain as quickly as
we can if we cannot get this caught out
of the brain that this whole area of
brain that you see here in green the
whole area will be dead most likely he
may permanently have some weakness on
that right side and he may not be able
to speak normally in the future at all
[Music]
this hospital is pioneering another
data-driven technology that could save
lives Carol Reed is being prepped for
open-heart surgery an operation that
itself carries a significant risk of a
stroke so you know there's a lot of
people actually that have strokes during
surgery now we see it more than we would
like to see it certainly and some people
get better but there's a number of
people the trouble is strokes can't
usually be detected until the operation
is over it's a risk that Carol is all
too familiar with her own mother
suffered a stroke during an operation
did they know about it nobody knew until
she came to and you know little time it
passed and she wasn't right a couple of
days today
Carol will be the world's first patient
to have her brain monitored for signs of
a stroke during heart surgery it's an
innovation that could transform the
outcome for heart surgery patients
across the world as Carol goes under the
knife this scanner uses data collected
on hundreds of patients to identify
clots that might be passing to her brain
[Music]
for the next six hours the scanner
constantly monitors her blood flow
[Music]
finally Carol's operation is
successfully completed and the risk of a
stroke passes
back in the intervention room Nick's not
out of the woods to remove a clot
doctors are inserting a catheter up
through his leg into his brain
it's known as a thrombectomy you know
what we did in this case is used a
smaller bore catheter to to grab the
clot this is actually the culprit for
all his symptoms and now we have it
outside the body and we have full
restoration of flow doctors are hopeful
the damage to Nick's brain has been
reversed just hours after the operation
he seems like a patient transformed data
driven innovation is rapidly spreading
in parts of the healthcare industry
services powered by artificial
intelligence are said to be worth 6.6
billion dollars by 2021 this technology
will significantly decrease the time in
which it takes us to institute
definitive care for our stroke patients
many more patients will be treated many
more patients will be cured and many
more patients will live the data
revolution sweeping the modern world has
a darker side to
day and night vast amounts of personal
information are quietly collected from
the 2.5 billion people with a smartphone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you go to sleep your phone doesn't
and it's a pretty reasonable assumption
that there are people who know when
you're asleep and when you're awake it's
not just smartphones the number of
connected devices collecting data about
their users is on the rise and expected
to reach 30 1 billion worldwide by 2020
and then there's the Internet every
single webpage you read every new site
you visit is pushing these little
software robots called cookies onto your
computer or your smartphone Hal Hudson
is The Economist's technology
correspondent what they're essentially
trying to do is figure out what you're
interested in so that they can show you
ads now that kind of tracking is making
its way deeper into the offline world
[Music]
while I've been running my watch have
been tracking my GPS location the way my
body moves in my pulse
Apple has patents to monitor your pulse
through your ear buds and all of that
data is getting sent up to the cloud to
build a profile on me and the way I run
today you don't even need to be on the
Internet to generate data points and add
to your hidden online profile
London is a sea of surveillance -
there's probably 20 CCTV cameras within
100 feet of us right now and every shop
has a Wi-Fi network that's tracking our
phones as we move through the street in
today's data economy you are the product
the data that gets generated whether
it's through a watch or through your
activity on the web or moving around a
city or your credit card swipes it's all
used for one thing and that's to profile
you to understand you as a consumer
advertisers don't have access to all
data in Europe strong rules protecting
personal privacy were introduced as top
companies from explicitly selling your
data but even they're not as secure as
they sound the trails of data that I
leave they're unique to me and so even
if you scrub my name off it it's kind of
like a fingerprint that's not attached
to a name and all you have to do is find
another fingerprint that is attached to
my name and all of a sudden all of the
anonymize data gets D anonymized on at
once
[Music]
[Applause]
Hilary Clinton should not even be
allowed to run for the presidency of the
United States she shouldn't be allowed
to run data driven technologies are even
being used to influence how people vote
after decades of lies and scandal her
corruption is closing in I'm Donald
Trump and I approve this message
politicians are increasingly turning to
data companies to mine the social media
profiles of voters and to hit them with
ever more targeted messages
[Applause]
during the 2016 US presidential election
the Trump campaign is believed to have
spent tens of millions of dollars on
this micro-targeting Trump's campaign
manager co-founded the company that
orchestrated this Cambridge analytical
it's my privilege to speak to you today
about the power of big data and
psychographics in the electoral process
most cambridge analytic are built what
it claimed it was a powerful program to
predict an influence choices at the
ballot box using the personal data of 50
million American Facebook users but it
appears they did so without users
permission in March 2018 the company's
British offices its global headquarters
were raided by authorities suspecting
the Facebook data had been obtained and
used unlawfully it's left some voters
feeling vulnerable and angry we have
realized that there are elaborate
profiles created about us that we can't
see David Carroll is an academic and
digital activist he is fighting
Cambridge analytical in the British
courts to demand the company hand over
all the data it has on him it's
important that people understand how
data can be used for good and for evil
where did they get our data what did
they do with it how did they use it who
did they share it with and do we have a
right to opt out of this
David believes tracking people across
the web to influence their voting
behavior poses a threat to personal
privacy and undermines their democratic
choices if his lawsuit is successful it
could open up data companies like
Cambridge analytical to mass legal
action from the US electorate
[Music]
now the tech giant's who profit from
personal data are also feeling a
backlash I think we clearly view it as a
mistake that we didn't inform people and
we did that in April 2018 CEO Mark
Zuckerberg was hauled in front of
Congress to address the company's
privacy violations your User Agreement
sucks now you know that and I know that
it's not just the Titans of tech coming
under closer scrutiny in communities
around the world people are looking more
carefully at how public bodies handle
their data skid-row
Los Angeles this neighborhood has one of
the largest homeless populations in
America it's an unlikely battleground
for the growing dispute over the use of
exploitation of data but it's from
headquarters here that a group of
citizen activists are preparing to take
on the authorities led by Jaime Garcia
and Hamid Khan to stop the LAPD spying
coalition claims law enforcement
agencies are using data in a way that is
unfair and biased against certain
communities today the activists are on
their way to City Hall we definitely
expect a lot of the community to be
there we've been organizing it's been a
long time coming
we gotta expose it we got to dismantle a
that are we gonna just call their lives
and their conspiracies and all of these
bogus programs but the programs that
have so unnerved people in this
community are being hailed by others as
the future of policing in an effort to
tackle crime the Los Angeles Police
Department is using a novel approach
called predictive policing rampart
division deploys a controversial
data-driven software called print pol
basically tells you the locations of
where we're predicting that the crime is
going to happen so every morning we get
our email from pred poll that tells us
where our missions are going to be for
day watch and p.m. watch so the email
gets sent directly to us we'll print it
out for the officers and it looks
something like this
Fred Pohl predicts crime by analyzing
data from the past several years it
examines three sources the crime type
the location and the time it then runs
them through an algorithm that
identifies 500 by 500 foot locations
that officers should Patrol
and whatever you can do to give you the
advantage in the situation helps us come
out on top
Sergeant David rich has been patrolling
the streets of LA for 23 years today
he's using data not tip-offs to predict
where crime will happen and preempted so
here we are that that intersection that
that's have been identified as a
problematic area as far as thefts
vehicle related crimes
so in this pred Pohl area the lot of
vehicle crime has been reported so I'm
gonna check out a car up here make sure
everything's on the up-and-up
statistically speaking if there's more
police officers within an area you know
somebody who's looking for an
opportunity to maybe break into a car
they may be less likely to do that
so simply being present is actually a
deterrent
the LAPD is trailing another program
that goes one step further to identify
and track people it assesses will be the
criminals of tomorrow
Anthony is an ex-offender
and activist who believes his past has
made him a target for the police just
justifying profiling the communities
they're already targeting under the
guise of science and objectivity it just
kind of throw a white dragnet that
you're all gang members and then when
you put on this fire on pit it does the
algorithm spits out a risk assessment
you're put on this bulletin operation
laser uses a point system to rank
individuals based on their past behavior
the higher your score the greater the
chance you will end up on a list of
people who according to the data are
most likely to rear fend for LAPD Chiefs
these data-driven technologies are an
efficient way to reduce crime data has
been critically important to the police
department and how we serve the
community but researchers at Cornell
University Library found that systems
like Craig Poll are susceptible to
so-called feedback loops where police
are repeatedly sent back to the same
neighborhoods regardless of the true
crime rate
back at City Hall members of the stop
LAPD spying coalition are poised for the
start of la's first-ever public hearing
on predictive policing now the police
must listen directly to their concerns
about racial profiling when we look at
the data that the police are collecting
that data is inherently biased all of
those things show a great impact on the
black and poor community and they are
patrolled they are surveilled they are
monitored they are watched and they're
harassed because they're presumed guilty
and I was in blue request that we give
the department the opportunity to speak
and be heard
thank you there are issues when it comes
to the crime stats for instance and I
acknowledge that there there are there
may be built-in biases to that as a
reported crime but we are trying to get
better the campaign is a demanding that
the police release more details about
how their predictive policing program
works
hearing right now is no reassurance to
us that you are transparent and you are
telling us what is really going on in
the city we actually had to file
lawsuits to make you be transparent what
we had to spend $400 of our own [ __ ]
money
to make you be transparent and so for me
data-driven policing begs one question
what data will be used to target arrests
banished and destroy black and brown
communities race do you really want an
audit of predictive policing programs
credit colon operation laser weights the
[ __ ] is twisting abolish abolish police
want to find out how people have been
damaged how their civil rights are human
rights have been violated and give them
an opportunity to actually receive
reparations if things have been violated
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's critics that are guarding rights
of people and that's they should do that
but I'm not sure it's a valid argument
but it's one that they should raise if
we were using something else there will
be critics it's just the way it is it's
frustratingly slow progress for citizen
groups like the coalition as they
campaign for greater clarity on how
data-driven programs work but at least
it's a campaign that here in America
they are free to pursue in China there's
precious little discussion about the
ethics of data use and here the state is
already using data in an effort to
control the behavior of its citizens
journalist leo who is barred from some
hotels he can't buy property he can't
even take a high-speed train
[Music]
we show him Indiana Nishi are they good
you should find Angie Miranda honey Joey
take a teeny someone no quitter
yeah me and also when I'm in trouble the
government here is building a social
credit system using individuals data
that's all we are
pinging sound seek out the hole would
your fashion timber up shop negative
thing go wrong well no adhesive did
before was really good
the Chinese government wants this social
credit system to monitor the
trustworthiness of its 1.4 billion
citizens and to monitor their compliance
with social norms and rules
this could eventually include close
surveillance of their activities both
online and in the wider world
behavior deemed antisocial such as
crossing at a red light smoking on a
train or obstructing footpaths with
bikes could lead to punishments leo who
was placed on a blacklist in 2017 after
a dispute about the payment of a court
fine
well games about don't know what didn't
alcohol she got what you actually have
intentionally being guy there you go
diggity new different aspects of the
system are still being trialed but 12
million people have already been slapped
with domestic travel bans for bad
behavior
Gianluca hard Zuma incontinent a
gasogene you may open door the Pangaea
position has a coupon gender originated
on pan problems and her dildo Choji
Maori virtually shut up
as the global data revolution
accelerates its ethics are set to come
under ever closer scrutiny debate is
already raging over how to hold
companies and governments accountable
for how they use data in Western
democracies checks and balances could
prevent the kind of exploitation some in
China are already facing but will they
[Music]
woman be assistance 8 how similar en yng
go she's a million doula
come on crazy I'm tamago tamago
[Music]
you
[Music]